de 4 a 6 meses la ex presidenta interina
de bolivia jeanine áñez tendrá que estar
dos meses más en prisión preventiva la
base legal de la decisión es la
ampliación de los riesgos de
obstaculización y de fuga expuesta por
la fiscalía el ministerio público y la
procuraduría un veredicto que no
sorprendió a la defensa de la ex
mandataria preocupados por otro tema la
salud de su clienta debido a que padece
hipertensión los abogados de agnès
obtuvieron una orden para que fuera
trasladada a una clínica pero en la
madrugada del sábado la expresidenta fue
llevada a otro centro carcelario y no a
un centro de salud esto es un abuso una
injusticia y están atentando contra la
vida de mi madre mi madre necesita con
urgencia atención médica el director
general de régimen penitenciario juan
carlos limpias aclaró que la decisión
del juez fue revocada y que el instituto
de investigaciones forenses será el
encargado de verificar el estado de
salud de años
con todo lo que tenemos en el centro
penitenciario de miraflores más allá de
los instrumentos
de primera necesidad que teníamos en el
centro de obrajes ahí contamos con
bastantes instrumentos que van a
permitir el cuidado y garantizar sobre
todo el derecho a la salud limpia señaló
que para evitar cualquier tipo de
susceptibilidad y tras una coordinación
entre el gobierno de luis arce y el alto
comisionado de las naciones unidas se
autorizó que una representación de la
onu pueda ingresar a la cárcel para
asegurarse del bienestar de agnès la ex
presidenta interina de bolivia es
acusada de participar en un supuesto
golpe de estado contra el ex presidente
evo morales en 2019 bajo los delitos de
sedición terrorismo y conspiración luego
de una denuncia de una ex diputada del
más el movimiento oficialista